this episode is sponsored by 80 000
hours 80 000 hours is a non-profit that
aims to help people have a positive
impact with their career head to 80
000.org
microcosmos to start planning a career
that could potentially help solve one of
the world's most pressing problems
[Music]
what you're watching right now
is something that james our master of
microscopes had never seen before and
given how much of the microcosmos he's
watched
anything that's new to him is thrilling
to us
what he'd found were those two luxxodies
you see stuck together
waltzing around in a very public display
of conjugation
while there are ciliates that frequently
dally around in sexual reproduction
for others including these luxodies
it's just not a common sight
so james kept his camera focused on them
following their progress
but in the process of watching this
population of luxoties
james would find something much stranger
going on in the microcosmos
something that would start innocently
enough
but that would end up in a place far
darker than he had anticipated
the scene in front of you right now is
filled with luxoties
more of those freshwater ciliates we
were just watching
the smaller species are called luxoty
striatus
and the larger ones are called loxodes
magnus
and that's what we're following around
right now
a luxoty's magnus navigating a field of
debris and other organisms
but
why
in a screen full of these organisms
why are we following this one
well
this luxoty's magnus is large
so large that it was able to eat a
rotifer
those funny animals we often see getting
bullied by their single-celled neighbors
and james meant to quickly capture one
of those instances before moving on
as the loxodies turns
you can sometimes see the outline of the
rotifer
taking up space in that grayish oval
area but what james realized as he was
watching and maybe you've caught on to
this as well
that rotifer is moving
it's alive
twisting and turning inside of the food
vacuole it's been stuffed into
and when james realized that he had to
keep recording
because there are stories out there of
rotifers fighting back
of them stretching themselves and
piercing away at the ciliate that had
the gall to eat them
until finally they poke through the body
that's attempting to digest them and
escape
so yeah james wanted to see if he could
watch that happen
to see if he could watch the rotifer
triumph for once
if only it were that easy
but that's getting ahead of ourselves
let's just sit here for a bit and watch
the rotifer at work
this is one of those episodes where i'll
be quiet for a bit and then chime in as
the rotifer's journey takes shape
and for now the story is straightforward
the rotifer tumbles and stretches and
the shape of its captor shifts in
response
expanding in width as the rotifer
refuses to be digested
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
if it seems like the rotifer is
sometimes putting up less of a fight
you'll have to excuse it
the conditions it's facing inside the
luxoty's food vacuole are intense
a bath of acid meant to eat away at its
body and render all of its multicellular
complexity into a well-digested stew
the fact that it survived this long
seems like a small miracle
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
[Music]
at this point the luxodies is passing
alongside a field of rotifers
the sisters of the very rotifer the
loxodies is trying to digest
and you can see them making that same
telescoping motion as their trapped
sibling
just from the anchored safety of a piece
of debris
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
perhaps it seems like the rotifer is
making all this movement for nothing
but just wait
this
this is the moment where the rotifers
escape begins in earnest it's managed to
tear a chunk out of the loxodies
ripping out an escape route that the
rotifer's head can start to peek out of
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just watch as it keeps that movement
going
the gaping hole in the loxodies growing
larger and larger as the rotifer
continues its work
the loxodes seems unperturbed
continuing to swim as if its insides
aren't being torn apart
but with enough time and enough poking
and prodding
the rotifer escapes its acid prison
making its way once more into the
microcosmos
this is a moment to celebrate right
we've been watching this rotifer try and
try and try for minutes
and here we are now with all the success
to show for it as it sets up a new home
for itself
that's what james thought too
except that he quickly realized that
something was wrong
the rotifer wasn't alone
it was actually inside another rotifer
or rather what had once been a rotifer
what had once been its mother
the acids of the luxoty's food vacuole
had eaten her body away
digesting and decomposing it
until all that was left
was an exoskeleton that protected the
young rotifer
living within her
while rotifers hatch from eggs there are
species that hatch from eggs that are
still tucked away inside of their
mothers
this trait is called ovo-viva parity
and it's found in various amphibians
insects and sharks
and yes rotifers like this one using
their body to shield their young
and yes the young rotifer survived
but as james watched a more cruel truth
emerged
the young rotifer was now stuck
the same cuticle that had protected the
rotifer from the acids of the loxodies
would now hold it forever
rigid and uncaring to its former life as
that rotifer's mother
the next day confirmed the valiant young
rotifer's tragic end
stuck within the confines of its
mother's cuticle
there towards the bottom of your screen
no longer pushing and shoving
but motionless in depth
and as for the luxoties
we don't know what happened to it
but given the capacity of its family for
regeneration
it probably survived with little injury
perhaps it swam by its former meal
unaware of their previous encounter
a battle waged a battle lost and the
world moving on around them both just
the same
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and thank you again to 80 000 hours for
sponsoring today's episode
80 000 hours is a non-profit that aims
to help people have a positive impact
with their career
the direction of your career path is a
big life decision and 80 000 hours has a
lot of free resources to help you plan
and research what options might be best
for you
they've got fantastic free resources
including decision making tools a
constantly updated job board and even a
podcast where they have in-depth
conversations with experts in the
world's most pressing problems and
discuss what you can do to help solve
them
eighty thousand hours wants to help you
find a career that does good in the
world and all of their provided
resources are free they're a non-profit
and their only aim is to help you find a
fulfilling high-impact career
click our link in the description or go
to 80 thousand hours dot org slash micro
cosmos to be sent a free copy of their
in-depth career guide to start learning
how you could have a high impact career
this will also sign you up for their
newsletter where they send updates on
their research and high-impact job
opportunities
before we go we'd also like to thank all
of our patreon patrons whose names
you're seeing on the screen right now
if you'd like to help support this
channel so we can keep bringing you
bizarre stories like this one you can
head on over to patreon.com
journey2micro
[Music]
if you'd like to see more from our
master of microscopes james weiss you
can check out jam and germs on instagram
and if you'd like to see more from us
there's probably a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you